mike you brought up something i want to
get to pat's question right there so you
talked about the development of khomeini
so obviously the agency and without
going into details you can't you're
tracking
the intellectual change the evolution of
thought and the evolution of aggression
i mean you got people like manuel
noriega from the perfect little pond to
the pain in the ass and when he became a
pain in the ass we went down there and
stuck him in a florida prison right yeah
and so you see that there's a lot talk
today in the ukraine that said that
people looking at putin and these are
people that are on cnn msnbc fox
everywhere and they're saying
it really looks in the last five years
there's been a change in him and he's a
little off rails
are you seeing that
no i don't think he's i mean yeah i've
heard that or maybe there's been
assessments you know
yeah
look
that but putin's a good example of this
and it's it's
what we're talking about is
yeah the big question right now is that
the intel point here that everyone's
trying to collect on is what's his plans
and intentions right so that's saying
we're going to get inside this guy's
head what do you have to do to do that
there's a [ __ ] ton of assessment that
goes on you're looking for again points
of access you're looking for recruitment
of targets that might be able to tell
you what the hell's going on uh with
putin the honest guys too there's nobody
really knows except for putin at this
point you know it's a heavy lift to to
collect on that target so
you know i i i'm not
i'm not surprised by this i think the
the idea that there was uh
contact between romini and and the uh
the us government to me makes perfect
sense because that's what we you see
that in other locations countries
throughout history as well they're you
know they're looking to build up their
power base they're looking you know for
a line of communication and and yeah the
the agency or or any intel service is
out there trying to understand what the
hell's going on because they're that's
what they're told to do
but
uh
yeah i forgot my lane to train you know
i don't tell you what the evolution of
you
all my senses
but you know what i will say here's what
i will say
i trust my enemies more than my allies
let me say why
i trust my enemies more than my allies
because every morning my enemies wake up
at least they're honest they want to do
whatever they can to put me out of
business
my allies i don't necessarily fully know
their incentives and their motives i 100
know the incentive the motives of my
enemy i know the enemy wants to do
whatever they can to have an upper edge
over me i'm naive if i don't believe
that okay
but with your allies you don't
necessarily know what is their next 10
moves maybe you're a move number three
but you're dispensed you know your
what's the word dispense uh you're uh
you can be
dispensed
in move number eight you're like oh he's
acting like an ally but what is really
his motive being an ally versus the
enemy is like look i want to kill you
it's that simple i want to put you out
of business
i trust
that russians motives
are more honest than anybody else's
that's sitting there saying oh my gosh
iran defending ukraine yeah yeah i don't
trust what the hell iran is doing saying
stuff about ukraine i don't trust that i
trust the fact that putin's saying
that's our land
we're going to take it here's what we're
doing
not in a positive trust there's a trust
of a very honest trusted enemy so for me
when i'm sitting here thinking
you know his playbook you don't like the
playbook but you know the playbook
yeah i i know fully
this is a true believer we're dealing
with that knows what he wants and is
going after it well he's been he's been
very consistent so to answer your
question people think is he going off
the rails no he's consistent in his
moves whether it's
you know what he did in crimea what he
did in chechnya what he you know didn't
abkhazia what he didn't sell i mean it's
it it's the same thing that he's been
doing and he's been very clear to your
point he's been very honest about
you know the fall of the soviet union
was the greatest tragedy of the 20th
century and he believes that and he said
it and repeatedly and and his intent has
always been to recreate a sphere of
influence so he is being very honest
about this so i think when people say oh
my god we can't understand what he's
doing
it's what he does right
assembling what he views as mother
russia i fully agree with what you're
saying is that you 100 trust your
enemies because you know exactly what
their motivation is yeah whereas your
allies you might not be sure what is
down the line like i think of the movies
like even in batman um or the dark
knight or even in like the movies like
the town you're robbing a bank together
but you know who joker is exactly but as
soon as you get well he knows that the
cops or the batman is going to come
after him and that's his enemy but as
soon as they get the money boom he kills
a couple of his guys boom he keeps all
the money so the next question here is
we know putin's the enemy right i mean
that's fair to say
but the next question is our ally here
is this guy zielinski what do we truly
know about him what is he really our
ally does he what does he want from the
world that's i think the big question
here
yeah this degree is that
there's degrees of
good and bad right i mean it's like
the agency
one thing you you learn very quickly is
it's nothing's black and white and yet
you know the world wants to frame
everything that way right so now the
social media story is oh my god you know
the the ukraine well look ukraine had a
lot of problems right corruption being
you know up the top of the list so and
there's a very difficult history there
in with ukraine and so
we just have to be aware that it doesn't
change the fact that putin's an [ __ ]
and they're dead i'll look over time
again and um
that's just what the file tells me and
so i think uh
i'm sorry thank you very much see you
next week guys
tom ellsworth goes missing it hasn't
seen her in 60 to 90 days but
the the you know i guess the point being
is that
with zielinski um
yeah you you just have to be pragmatic
about all this and and the one thing i
do worry about is is how simple
everything gets framed right and how
quickly the news story you know becomes
this three-minute bite of of everything
and
yeah if you look at what we're doing
right now um in terms of i mean to bring
iran by back into it if you look at the
negotiations indirect that we're having
with iran and utilizing russia
now
right to in part to try to you know
develop a alternative
supply line for oil
and in part and this is where i'm very
cynical it's because you know the
current administration here in the u.s
realizes we can't suffer these [ __ ]
gas prices for very long because the
midterm elections are coming up
and so we got to do something so for
political reasons maybe i'm being
cynical you know they're pushing forward
on this negotiation because they damn it
we got to get these sanctions off so we
can let the iranian oil flow so we can
keep prices down so we don't get our
asses kicked in the election if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]